>>> HE IS THE BIDEN ADMINISTHAN
TD ETRE.
BO OF A RUSSIAN INVASI IEIT
VE SHOW OF UNITY.
AND WHILE CORRTLNG TO PR WILBA L
E
S,S GHRG STRATEGIC FAILURE, ONED
ISE OF THE CF
STRAS TO DIVIDE ADVERSA
Y OREIGNOP.
MON OVE
5,
CHENDSHI LIM
WHLYTWO POWERSCLOSER TO ONE ANR.
TOUGH SANCTIONS AGAINST RUSSIA C
EVEN MORENTHIMPORTFRHET MOSCOW U
INSTITUTIONS TO EVADAM L RESTRI.
WE ANY
IN 2014  BOTS WEALSOHID TO SUPP
INSIUKRA
ITOTXAONCR
IA IGEORGIA AND HAS AT IAITAN AR
SONTY. AVEES T FROMCHING THEM TS
TH IDEOLOGS TRIUMPHED OVER
GTON THESE
UKRAINE,NDD TERRITORY ORS, G
IN TSEALII. REPORTEDLED C ARE TO
MORE THAN ACG THE UNITED STATES
FORCE, IT HARDERED IOPPONENTS
ACTUALLY BENEFITS FROMLOL STABI
IS DIFFERENTS  THAT SEEKS GRT G
OWDSNATIONNOMIR IT T
AS ROBERT ING NOTED IN
RELI I20, BEIJ
IS NOT TRYING EPLACE T
BAN WTOOTHER U.N. ITIT YIE DOM
ROLEN EMIN THE PAST
AGAINST ROGUE D NORTH  ERS NT ML
FREQUE OR THE
UNTATES.
MU TO TO COMS IN THE OF
DO PNACTIN
MEAS TH ANN ANENESS.
RO G CATESMAN WATO VAN BISMARCK
THATYET GTON INGER,O WISC AST.S
HTE THE CURRENTERAN
PERHAPWH NEEDES T
A GER, BUT S
IN OORT TO  BRELATIONSHIP WITIN
THAT IN ANHAT HENRY S  SE COLD D
STRATEGY, WASHINGTON LUISSTETI
TETIONNOUNCEN AND RTH KOREA TOR.
T' THA D
NOO ENDURE A LOND
COSTLYISADVENTUR